este encuentro en Alemania en el que
participan más de 40 países muchos de
ellos integrantes de la otan sin embargo
también hay otras naciones que a través
de este grupo de coordinación dan apoyo
militar y humanitario a Ucrania es
extremadamente importante en este
momento pues lo que está programando
Ucrania es esa llamada contraofensiva
para recuperar territorio tomado por las
fuerzas de Moscú ya no solo desde el 24
de febrero del año pasado Cuando comenzó
la invasión a gran escala sino desde
2014 esta contraofensiva tiene planes
para llegar a crimea qué es lo que
llaman los ucranianos la victoria final
sin embargo esta reunión también tiene
reclamos de parte de Ucrania que asegura
que muchas de las armas prometidas por
accidente no han ido llegando a tiempo
especialmente munición dicen que ha
habido demoras en esta entrega lo que
hace que se haya pospuesto esta ofensiva
pero también ha tenido consecuencias en
el terreno especialmente en esa lucha en
el don básico especialmente en esa dura
batalla de backmud que ellos dicen que
ha costado la vida de muchísimos
soldados lo mismo no repiten cuando
vamos al frente quienes combaten allí
dicen que si hubieran tenido más
munición y más armamento la historia en
esa zona todavía en control de Ucrania
al menos parte de la ciudad sería
diferente sin embargo allí lo que
también hemos visto es la presencia del
ministro de defensa ucraniano que ha
hecho una actualización de lo que
pretende Ucrania en los próximos meses y
se ha reunido con el Secretario de
Defensa norteamericano el país que más
ha ayudado a Ucrania le ha explicado la
situación ellos han prometido enviar con
anticipación los tanques Abraham que
supuestamente iban a llegar el año
entrante Ahora parece que llegarán este
otoño a apoyar esta contraofensiva y
también el Secretario de Defensa
estadounidense apoyaba y daba las
gracias a los países aliados por seguir
Unidos después de que se hubiera
filtrado sus papeles del pentágono en el
que decía que Estados Unidos espiaba no
solamente a Ucrania sino a otros países
aliados